[Música]
el Papa Francisco está en la República
democrática del Congo y luego visitará
ciudad del sur un viaje que fue aplazado
por dolencias de rodilla del pontífice Y
que ahora ha generado gran expectativa
por la visibilización de los conflictos
en esos territorios vamos a conversar
con Marcial Sánchez gadetl ser doctor en
historia y experto en historia de la
Iglesia Católica Marcial gracias a usted
y cuál es el impacto de la visita papal
en este año a ese país precisamente
Muchas gracias por la invitación y poder
conversar este tema
yo creo que las visitas de los sumos
pontífices son importantes porque de
alguna otra forma la gente que está
esperándolos esperan de alguna otra
forma algún mensaje que los ayude a
poder enfrentar la realidad que viven
pero este papa va como jefe de estado y
no podemos olvidar ese punto de vista
debido que
hay que recordar que el Vaticano ha
ayudado económicamente a muchos países
africanos durante mucho tiempo y
fundamentalmente a través del esfuerzo
que hacen algunas fundaciones en temas
humanitarios entonces Obviamente que el
papa también al margen de juntarse con
una buena parte de la población en este
caso en el Congo como ya lo hemos visto
también firma acuerdos que Son acuerdos
a nivel de un estado con otro estado
bueno la importancia que tiene es
radical porque está en un lugar hoy día
donde hay un problema de inestabilidad
hay que recordar que nosotros tenemos
las primeras elecciones en el año 2006
en la República democrática del Congo
por lo tanto tenemos una una
democracia muy joven tenemos una
estabilidad de acuerdo que recién
debería estar germinando pero
lamentablemente no ha podido ser así
debido a que hoy día hoy día estamos
viendo que en ese país hay muchos
muchas fuerzas que se están enfrentando
básicamente
para poder hacerse cargo de la riqueza
que tiene ese país hay que recordar que
en el Congo en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
y posterior la Segunda Guerra Mundial
fue el país que donde más extrajo uranio
de acuerdo y hay que recordar también
que la bomba atómica fue hecha con
uranio de ese lugar por lo tanto la
visita del Papa es un bálsamo solamente
nada más que eso porque en términos
reales él puede decir mucho pero es bien
complejo cuando las palabras se
enfrentan a las armas y este papa Está
tratando de enfrentar con palabras una
situación muy compleja que se está
viviendo no solamente en el Congo y no
en muchos países de África es que
definitivamente por política del
Vaticano el papa nunca puede asumir una
posición en términos digamos
diplomáticos pero desde el año 85 no
visitaba un Papa la República
democrática del Congo el último en
hacerlo fue Juan Pablo Segundo que
aterrizó en el continente africano
además 16 veces así que esta visita
después de tanto tiempo despierta sin
duda emoción entre los católicos del
país Pero además y se lo pregunto desde
su punto de vista de pues es una
oportunidad para revisar el conflicto
que que no que no no siempre tiene la
relevancia necesaria a nivel
internacional no lo estamos viendo en
las noticias internacionales todos los
días
es que el tema es ese África no se ve
todos los días en las noticias y debería
verse hoy día África es el país es el
continente que tiene el treinta y tres
por ciento de pobreza a nivel mundial es
un es un continente muy rico y que ha
sido avasallado por su historia es cosa
de recordar solamente la época
colonialista en el siglo 19 y
posteriormente en este país en
específico
en el año 1960 y posteriormente con la
instalación de un dictador de acuerdo
donde la Cia tuvo mucho que ver en esto
por lo tanto y cuál es el punto aquí el
punto son las riquezas que tienen estos
países y que han sido demandadas
inescrupulosamente como ya lo dijo el
papa ayer por las diferentes potencias
Claro que es importante la visita papa
después de tanto tiempo como tú muy bien
decías Juan Pablo Segundo estuvo en este
lugar pero sabes más que dentro de una
relación de acuerdo política a nivel de
Estados Yo creo que es un es un llamado
a la paz que pueda hacer este hombre y
que también la gente sienta que
efectivamente no está sola yo
sinceramente cuando uno observa o a mí
me pasa cuando yo observo las noticias
de África que siempre no aparecen o uno
tiene que buscarlas en ciertos lugares
para poder entender lo que sucede ahí
es como que hay una parte del planeta
que nosotros queremos tapar me acuerdo
que Galeano un historiador
latinoamericano en algún momento dijo
que América Latina era el patio trasero
de Estados Unidos yo me atrevería a
decir que hoy día África es el patio
trasero del mundo nadie lo toma en
cuenta y hoy día gracias a Esta visita
estamos observando el gran problema que
no solamente tiene el Congo sino África
en general mire haciendo la salvedad de
que France 24 tiene de hecho un programa
que está completamente dedicado al
continente africano y que tratamos de
mantenerlo dentro de nuestra agenda
noticiosa constantemente si falta mucho
esta presencia de la riqueza y de la
cultura africana Pues en nuestros medios
de comunicación ahora sobre eso
precisamente África es un continente
absolutamente diverso en su cultura y en
sus creencias religiosas en el caso de
la República democrática del Congo más o
menos la mitad de la población es
católica que no es tanto si se compara
por ejemplo con países latinoamericanos
donde esa mayoría la ciudadanía que
practica la religiosidad Católica Así
que cuál es Cuál es la percepción del
catolicismo en un país como el Congo que
además está atravesado por unas
creencias católicas que son diferentes a
las occidentales
qué buena pregunta qué buena observación
hiciste de France 24 yo creo que
efectivamente hay medios de comunicación
que se han preocupado del tema Uno de
ellos es este en donde estamos
conversando con respecto al mundo al
mundo religioso en el Congo el 55,8% son
católicos y una cifra importante ya que
el 80,63% según los guarismos los
últimos guarismos son cristianos
Claro que es importante la visita de un
representante de la Iglesia Católica
porque más de la mitad de la población
adhiera esa religión pero también hay un
sincretismo importante con las
religiones de acuerdo ancestrales que
hay ahí y obviamente eso te va generando
una forma distinta fundamentalmente en
el tema de la ritualidad
yo me recuerdo no hace mucho por ejemplo
Hoy día hay Biblias que se están
llevando de acuerdo a los idiomas
originarios de los lugares porque aquí
hay que recordar que este es un país que
estuvo
nace de una invasión bandú estamos
hablando Ya bueno dos mil años atrás
pero
desde ahí en adelante siempre ha estado
invadida y fundamentalmente mucho tiempo
por el mundo belga entonces obviamente
que la intromisión del mundo occidental
ya lleva mucho tiempo y esa intromisión
del mundo occidental también trae esto
de las religiones Entonces cuando tú
observas lo que son las religiones
ancestrales que van quedando al lado van
quedando al alero de la vida cotidiana
de ellos y tienen que hacer un
sincronismo con estas nuevas religiones
instauradas desde el mundo occidental te
observas que nacen otras formas
culturales que hay que observar el
problema Sí es que el ser humano es ser
humano en cualquier parte del mundo y el
mundo humanitario hoy día
está muy conflic al observar esto porque
obviamente tenemos una humanidad que
viene saliendo una pandemia de acuerdo
pero se enfrenta una realidad en donde
Acá hay una pandemia permanente y es una
pandemia permanente de hambre y una
pandemia permanente de estar siempre
bajo la leyero de otro y cuando quieres
independizarte lo que hacen los otros
que ya estuvieron ahí Quieren seguir
teniendo el poder Y lamentablemente no
te dejan crecer y ese es un problema
grave que hoy día sucede no solamente en
el Congo